what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and it finally happened
the black bulls are together in one
place and the final epic battle to save
captain yami's life is about to begin
we've waited so long for yami to return
to the story and for the black bulls to
fight together as one after their time
skip power-ups that moment is now
finally here so let's get into it you
guys know the drill if you enjoy our
black lore videos and you want to see
more leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it really helps
with the youtube algorithm and if you're
new to the channel or you haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications unless you
go through the steps of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting the
option that says all youtube will not
recommend our videos to you you will
never see them so please do that right
now you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned in the
previous chapter we got the big twist
that morris is the new devil host for
lucifer and that he has that extremely
overpowered reconstruction magic we also
witnessed a bunch of the black bulls
bursting through the walls and rushing
at morris just as he was about to kill
lotus and dorothy the new chapter begins
with the black bulls's entrance gray is
like wait why do we just break the whole
freaking palace and gauche is like hey
who cares this is the home base of the
enemy but gordon rightly points out that
this palace actually belongs to the
spade kingdom royal family so
technically they just broke yuno's house
but it is what it is best girl vanessa
then tries to get everyone back on track
meanwhile lotus and dorothy are grateful
that the black bulls are here because
they were literally about to get bodied
by morris get it bodied because he was
using the bodies of those devils to
attack them anyway morris is aware that
at least two of the black bulls have
arcane stage magic and the others have
very interesting magic as well because
of this morris can't wait to dissect
them all and perform experiments on them
because you know that's just a normal
everyday mad scientist thing morris uses
all of that devil flesh around him to
create massive claws which he then uses
to swipe at the black bulls vanessa
tries to use the red thread of fate to
negate morris attacks but morris implies
that because of his new devil power up
his magic is now capable of interfering
even with concepts also if he so much as
touches the black bulls they will be
done for now i'm not 100 sure what
morris means when he says that his magic
can interfere even with concepts i
assume he means that his magic is able
to take on not just conventional magic
but also abstract magical concepts like
the red thread of fate i wonder if this
means that morris will be able to
counter asta's anti-magic as well so far
anti-magic has been super effective
against devils but it's only a matter of
time before asta comes face to face with
an opponent who has an effective way of
dealing with anti-magic morris may be
that opponent and as the rest of this
chapter demonstrates we will find out
whether morris is that opponent very
soon as morris's giant demonic claw
things rush towards the black bulls gray
uses her incredible transformation magic
to transform the demonic arms into a
bunch of pretty flowers we then learn
through a flashback that grey's true
magic is something more than just
transformation magic transformation
magic is supposed to only change how
things look it changes their appearance
not their fundamental structure however
grey's magic has the potential to change
the very structure of things so rather
than being conventional transformation
magic it is more accurately called
transmutation magic man as soon as i saw
this it instantly reminded me of full
metal alchemist and personally i think
that this revelation about grey's magic
is very cool transmutation magic has so
much potential and i can't wait to see
all the ways that she is going to use it
in the future morris is impressed by
gray's abilities but rather than slowing
down he only accelerates his attacks on
the black bulls meanwhile gray is being
all nervous because she's next to gosh
and she's totally into him but gauche is
all chill and he just says shut up for
now and look at me damn i know gauche is
saying this because of his magic and
everything but it really sounds like
he's dropping some lines on grey as a
blushing grey looks at gauche he
activates his mirror magic and suddenly
a bunch of grey shadow clones appear
these clones are able to transmute the
rest of morse's attacks into flowers
allowing the black bulls to deal with
the increased number of attacks morris
who is now hilariously surrounded by
pretty flowers decides that now is the
time to use his other magic the one that
belongs to his devil lucifer morris
activates gravity magic presence of the
demon king the same spell that dante was
shown using before gravity should not be
something that grey's magic can
transform so by increasing the gravity
in that area morris can essentially
disassemble the black bulls and their
mecha headquarters and they can't do
anything to stop him because how do you
stop gravity itself and that is when
none other than henry steps up to the
plate during that earlier battle against
dante when yami was kidnapped henry felt
like he couldn't do a thing but this
time things are going to be different
that's because henry and gordon figured
something out together we see a
flashback in which gordon returns from 6
months of intense training with his
family during this training he learned
how to turn his poison into medicine he
is now able to turn curses into power
which allows henry to control the
effects of his curse
so instead of uncontrollably absorbing
magic from everyone around him henry is
now able to choose from where the magic
he drains is going to come from and of
course he decides to start draining
morris's magic henry also gets a haircut
for some reason like right then and
there in the middle of the fight he has
long hair one second and then short hair
the next i'm not exactly sure why this
happened but okay let's go with it
morris is shocked to find himself being
drained of his magic despite the fact
that he is supposed to be the one with
the strongest power and if that wasn't
bad enough for morris osta and the other
black bulls used that giant hole in
order to join up with grey gauche
vanessa gordon and henry but morris
remains defiant he has completed
countless experiments in order to turn
himself into the perfect devil host and
now with the power of lucifer behind him
he cannot be defeated at least that's
what he claims
but whether morris is the ultimate devil
host or just a mage from the diamond
kingdom means nothing to the black bulls
they are here to save their captain and
they won't let anyone or anything stand
in their way the final page of the
chapter shows an absolutely epic panel
of the black bulls assembled and ready
to face morris together osta is there
noel is there magna zora lux secret
finral charmy everyone is ready to go
they demand the return of their captain
and that is how this chapter ends the
black bulls are assembled in one place
for the first time in a very long time
our boy asta is there of course and i'm
sure noct is also there somewhere he
might be up to something but we'll have
to wait and see this means that the
final battle is upon us the final fight
for yami's life is here and even though
i personally believe that yami will be
successfully rescued soon rescuing yami
may not end up being the final act of
this arc remember that the second gate
is about to open and if that gate opens
lucifer will enter the human world in
his real body if this ends up happening
even once the black bulls rescue ami the
battle will not be over once that second
gate opens yami will just end up joining
the black bulls in fighting the
strongest devil lucifer in the flesh
make no mistake lucifer in his real body
will be stronger than any villain that
we've ever met before and defeating him
will not be an easy task by any stretch
of the imagination so far we've only
seen a preview of what lucifer's power
is truly like and since he's been around
since the beginning of this arc through
his whole partnership with dante and
also through his dark history with liebe
and asta's mom i am sure that the fight
against lucifer will be a deeply
emotional and extremely intense showdown
it will definitely take yami asta and
all the black balls working together in
order to take lucifer down and even that
may not be enough in the end but that's
not all there are other devils to think
about as well including of course
magikula in her true body bielzebub and
of course there's that mysterious time
magic devil who is most likely using the
fourth zograda sibling as his host at
this point it's hard to say whether
lucifer or the time devil will be the
final villain or whether the two of them
are going to team up against our heroes
together but whatever happens the final
showdown of this arc will completely
change everything we thought we knew
about the world of black clover we can
expect massive new power ups we can
expect insane teamwork with dozens of
overpowered magic attributes working
together as one and we can still expect
a lot more twists and turns along the
way there might even be a death or two i
dare not say it because it's black
clover but it could happen and i
wouldn't be surprised if we learned
something more about asta's father
before this arc is over so i can't wait
to see what happens next let me know
what you guys think are you as hyped as
i am that the black bulls are back
together and fighting in the same place
against the same enemy speaking of which
where exactly is knocked and what is he
up to is yami about to be rescued and
finally returned to the story and who
will be the final villain lucifer or the
time devil don't forget to leave your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this black glower video and
you want to see more in the future just
leave a quick like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and if you're
new to animal pro or you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
quick favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications i
often have people complaining that they
subscribed but they still don't get
notified about our videos and that's
because you really have to turn on all
notifications it's how youtube works you
can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror a big thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twego himself i also
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrada algital
pate heffa hinokami and water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the spike
kaido might be a gyarados dylan isidor
spidey life canal tungsten tarkis baked
buddhist monkey d quilly cody hebert and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven steelers on hell crews very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joanne
garcia fat boy games jessica rabbit and
jeremy phillips if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]
you